there's no legal requirement for schools
to provide health or mental health
services to their students colleges do
it because it's the right thing to do
and because it's prudent I think there's
a growing understanding and it's
something that we at the JED foundation
are trying to really make schools aware
of that it's in the schools and the
students best interest to provide a
really broad array of support services
to their students the the more we can
keep students on track doing well in
school and getting to the graduation
line the better it is for everybody
involved one of the big challenges in
providing services is that most schools
actually provide these services for free
it's very very rare for colleges to
charge for the mental health services of
course students and their parents would
say they're charging plenty already
but services are usually provided
without extra cost to the students and
that creates a real challenge for the
schools to balance the cost and benefit
of the range of services they are
providing the other challenge is that in
you know the 18 to 25 year old age group
many people have had either no
experience with health or mental health
care people who've had experiences as
teens often haven't had the greatest
experiences because they've often
actually been forced into treatment or
you know sent to treatment outside of
their own will so getting the people who
need treatment into the system is often
a very very significant challenge and
then it's a challenge for the system to
have the resources the personnel the the
number of clinicians and visits in order
to take care of everybody who needs care
the one thing we do know is that college
students drink more alcohol than their
non college attending 18 to 25 year old
cohort so clearly we know that college
is a risk factor for increase in alcohol
use and there are a series of problems
that are coincident with that and that
does present a serious concern we know
about a third of college students will
report an alcohol binge every two weeks
or so so that's a really significant
number and we know that there there are
a lot of negative consequences
associated with especially the the high
intensity drinking that sometimes goes
on we know that their fights that occur
obviously car accidents that occur and
unfortunately there's been tremendous
concern recently about the increasing
awareness around sexual assaults on
campus and we know about 2 percent of
students who drink report that they've
had a non-consensual sexual contact in
the context of drinking and while that
sounds like a low percentage the
denominator of that fraction they're
about 20 million students in college and
about 70% of them drink two percent of
70 percent of 20 million is something in
the range of three hundred thousand
incidents of non-consensual sexual
contact that's actually a staggering
number
leaving to college going away to college
especially if you're away from home for
the first time is a period of time of
tremendous excitement and opportunity
and you know thrilling challenges and
increased freedom and at the same time a
lot of things are happening it may be
the first time you've actually been or
spent time or lived away from home for
any significant period of time it's also
a time of great psychological and and
maturational development it's a time
where you're really making more strides
towards growing up towards establishing
goals in your life to establishing
serious relationships potentially
there's a lot happening in your brain
and there's a lot happening outside of
you in your life and a lot of decisions
and changes to contend with
there are ways you can prepare yourself
for that learning about you know basic
life skills learning how to take care of
yourself is one of the things hopefully
you'll have an opportunity to do while
you're in college but it's good to come
there with some of those skills already
in hand a lot of these challenges can
sometimes reflect themselves in
increased levels of anxiety or
depression
if you're feeling worried about yourself
if you're feeling different if you're
feeling that things are changing in some
way that's making you uneasy at almost
any school that you're attending there
are support services and help available
there's a counseling service you can
find out about it almost inevitably on
the school's website if you're in school
housing there are Ras who can help you
get connected there are people in
student services in the Dean of Students
office who can help you get connected to
support and care so there are a lot of
things you can do to learn more about
how to handle these challenges learn how
to deal with some of the academic
challenges through your academic
advisors but there are counseling
services who can provide more direct
clinical care if that's what you need
but the services and support is
available for you
you